today's episode is sponsored by blinka
Stu the app that lets you read or listen
to an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blink it's totally
free and get 25% off a subscription when
you go to blink ascom slash david pakman
I put the link right below this video I
really sort of went back and forth all
morning about whether I should talk
about this Barry Weiss situation or not
and I decided to talk about it at least
as an introduction into exploring
whether some bigger discussion is
required so let me explain to you what's
going on and then we'll talk about it
Bari Weiss was up until yesterday a New
York Times opinion columnist and
yesterday she wrote a resignation letter
which she published on her website and
the resignation letter led to the entire
sort of social media sphere being abuzz
different people for different reasons
but everybody from you know I think Don
Jr tweeted about it all the way to the
folks in the so-called intellectual dark
web and sort of like everybody in
between and I think what the letter says
is one piece of it and the reaction is
another piece and I want to talk about
both now Barry Weiss was hired by the
New York Times in 2017 to write about
culture and politics and she became
significantly more well-known when she
wrote a widely disseminated piece about
the intellectual dark web and she's
appeared on Bill Maher's program she's
appeared on a number of different
programs and when she published this
resignation letter yesterday the social
media space exploded for different
reasons but all with the assumption and
the understanding that this resignation
letter is a bombshell blockbuster
indictment of the New York Times and of
media intolerant media more generally
and you know during the day I was seeing
this stuff in little fits and spurts but
I was busy with this bogus urgent press
conference that Donald Trump held and
covering the expanding war
between the White House and the medical
community on coronavirus we had another
DEATH surged nearly a thousand deaths
record deaths in multiple states we had
multiple live streams yesterday so it
wasn't really until last night that I
even read the resignation letter I slept
on and I looked at it again today and I
have to tell you I've looked at this
thing six ways from Sunday I think the
phrases excuse me if I've got that one
wrong um I'm not sure that there is
actually that much to discuss in terms
of this being a bombshell
other than it really seems like the New
York Times isn't the right place for
Barry Weiss to do her writing now I want
to be really clear I don't dislike Barry
Weiss nor do I think her work is bad I
don't always agree with her conclusions
but she's done some reasonable work she
has done some interesting pieces about
ways in which anti-semitism is often
ignored or oppression is is not taken as
seriously when it comes to the Jewish
community and I've been talking about
that for a long time I think there's
different standards there I think she's
reasonably interested in that topic and
sort of does it does pretty good
coverage there she's way off on a whole
bunch of other stuff but that's okay
right like that's not a personal problem
I have with her that would apply to I
mean listen Andrew Sullivan who I'm
going to mention later a conservative
sometimes he says things I agree with
and a lot of what he says I disagree
with it doesn't mean I want him fired or
his voice suppressed or whatever the
case may be now let's dig into the
letter itself maybe the most notable
part of the letter is a paragraph about
the relationship between the New York
Times and social media where she says
quote Twitter is not on the masthead of
the New York Times but Twitter has
become its ultimate editor as the ethics
and mores of that platform have become
those of the paper the paper itself has
increasingly become a kind of
performance space stories are chosen and
told in a way to satisfy the narrowest
of audiences rather than to allow a
curious public to read about the world
and then draw their own conclusions I
was always taught that journalists were
charged with writing the first rough
draft of history now history itself
is one more ephemeral thing molded to
fit the needs of a predetermined
narrative in another paragraph she sort
of seems to issue an indictment of what
was allowed to take place at the New
York Times and says that quote showing
up for work as a centrist referring to
herself showing up for work as a
centrist that an American newspaper
should not require bravery clearly
implying that the New York Times has
become some kind of radical left-wing
publication and her centrism required
her to be brave to show up in the spite
of in in the face of and despite
recriminations and and you know all
sorts of attacks on her not physical but
ideological so in general she is arguing
that the New York Times increasingly is
catering to a very narrow audience and
that anybody looking to put out
something outside of that narrow scope
of opinion is just like not really
allowed or welcome at the New York Times
both from the point of view of the
publication but also just in terms of
her feeling like she was just not
treated particularly well at the New
York Times she wasn't in the in-crowd at
the New York Times because of her
differences of opinion which to me
relates more to a toxic work environment
than it is a criticism of the New York
Times as a journalistic institution and
that's where I get to my first sort of
primary point here when you see a letter
like this and then you start reading the
responses often the responses are very
generalized and it's sort of like are
people responding to what she says about
the New York Times as a media outlet or
what she says about the New York Times
as an employer because toxic work
environments are unfortunately very
common and we need to distinguish in
looking at her letter
what is she asserting about how she felt
while working at the New York Times
which is completely valid and what are
her criticisms about the New York Times
as a media institution which can be
argued and are up for debate I mean for
example she argues that the New York
Times is now catering to the narrowest
slice of the political spectrum if
that's the case it would be reflected
presumably in decreased viewership of
the New York Times because it appeals to
a smaller and smaller slice of the
population so we could look at that
empirically I happen to know what the
answer is but I don't think it's it's
particularly relevant to this story but
the New York Times is actually doing
quite well now you could argue well it's
because they've decided just to
criticize Trump okay but now now we're
in a gray area all of a sudden there's
some interesting criticisms that I want
to look at that focus on the media piece
that are much more broad than the New
York Times but the bombshell about the
New York Times that some are pointing to
here I'm just not seeing it now first
and foremost from the point of view of
opinion the New York Times is basically
a center-left publication they've
correctly mean listen to say they're
biased because they do a lot of Trump
critiques Donald Trump is a uniquely bad
actor who has done things no president
has done before where every week never
mind
you know sometimes every day there's a
new scandal so the New York Times as the
center-left paper that also does
investigative journalism has been
correctly criticizing a lot of Donald
Trump's presidency and remember there
was no big Pro Bernie voice at the New
York Times there was also no big Pro
Trump voice at the New York Times and
that's the point
it's center-left sort of in line with
MSNBC but they do more investigative
journalism which is a separate
department than the opinion side the New
York Times from an opinion perspective
seems widely in line with the Democratic
Party
both are center-left now if your problem
is I don't want the New York Times to be
center-left okay that now now we can
talk about that but the New York Times
of some radical place is just wrong it's
it's empirically wrong secondly there's
the idea of what is considered outside
the Overton Window for the New York
Times um
and Barry Weiss talked about talked
about this what is or isn't acceptable
to say or publish at the New York Times
and from Barry Weiss's perspective the
Overton Window is too narrow at the New
York Times
it doesn't include certain perspectives
and as a result she feels like her work
was demeaned and and not maybe given the
mentor seriousness that she believes it
deserves that's completely legitimate
and it genuinely does seem like her work
was not best placed at the New York
Times but that's not strikingly
different from saying the National
Review wouldn't be the right place
for a lot of stuff Fox News is not the
right place for a lot of stuff I believe
Barry Weiss is genuine when she says
that the environment at the New York
Times was not the right place for what
she writes and I still want her to write
and it's okay if the New York Times
isn't the right place
she also says that the work environment
was hostile in a day to day perspective
and I have no reason to doubt that there
is no shortage of toxic and hostile work
environments but let's not mix the two
things and and importantly she wasn't
silenced she wasn't fired she determined
she didn't like the work environment and
the way which her work was received and
that's a very different thing than the
bombshell that many people are making
this out to be now there's a separate
issue here
which we have to talk about in terms of
her criticism of the New York Times as a
journalistic endeavor and there's no
shortage of criticism of the New York
Times and in general I agree that too
many media outlets are catering to
social media as a primary doorway to
their content and social media and
shareability of content and journalism
has changed have the New York Times and
just about every media outlet behaves
but that is not the widespread
indictment that maybe some are making
her letter out to be so in total as I
read the piece I see very little that's
unique to the New York Times other than
Barry Weiss worked there and her
relationship to the Times is different
than to the National Review or some
other publication every media outlet has
biases which come from ideology or
corporate structure from availability
bias from a desire to maintain access to
people in positions of power whatever
else may be at the New York Times the
bias has sort of
shape at the wall street journal' the
bias has a different shape at the
Washington Post or the Washington Times
or Fox News or CNN or the David Pakman
show biases are shaped in different ways
that's a big complex issue that's widely
studied in media literacy classes but
the idea that some journalistic outlets
don't want a full range of political
opinion represented that's not new I
mean that applies to us right I control
the preponderance of certain types of
ideas that are put out on my program I
exclude some stuff there's some stuff
that would be a bad fit for this program
if it didn't work out for Barry Weiss at
the New York Times she's completely
right to leave and her critique of how
she felt from a personal perspective
there is completely valid but I don't
see the bombshell here that many are
making it out to be I'm willing to have
my mind changed now one last thing
Andrew Sullivan has also announced that
he's leaving the Atlantic at the end of
this week I would not be surprised if
there's some announcement coming about
some new endeavor where Barry Weiss and
Andrew Sullivan and maybe others are
going to be involved we'll see if we
soon learn about that we're seeing
something very interesting happening
over the last 24 to 48 hours in the
United States on the one hand you have
Donald Trump and the administration and
even many Republicans insisting
everything must open Disneyworld must
open schools must open and of course it
doesn't really make sense because if
schools had to close when we had a
hundred thousand active cases it's not
really following that it would be safe
to then open the schools when we have
two million active cases or close to it
but what's very interesting is that the
country
fortunately seems to be leaning in the
direction of reality and scaling back
plans to open rather than following the
obvious lies of Donald Trump and opening
more and more and why would they follow
Donald Trump over the last 48 hours the
Trump White House has released a list of
things dr. Anthony foul she got wrong
while Donald Trump was retweeting the
conspiracy theories of former game show
host Chuck Woolery governors and also
many mayors however have to deal with
the day-to-day of increasingly full icy
use increasing hospitalization rate
it's the mayor of Houston Texas
Sylvester Turner who's a Democrat is
proposing a strict to weak shot down
even the Republican governor in Texas
Greg Abbott is talking about stricter
gap guidelines they've put in a
mandatory mask order in California over
the last two days we've seen the
democratic governor Gavin Newsom say
indoor restaurants have to close again
close wineries close movie theaters
close zoos museums certainly bars must
close a Los Angeles and San Diego are
saying we're not opening schools the
fall semester the fall the school year
in the fall is going to start online
only Oregon has said once again no
gatherings of more than ten people
Kentucky Fried Chicken or I guess now
it's just called KFC they are telling
franchises in a lot of these states
you've got to stop indoor dining and
this makes sense and even the economic
arguments fall short because the short
term benefit of opening things too
quickly is going to backfire it's going
to evaporate and you're going to end up
with a much worse economic situation if
you have a big relapse effect and in the
end the long term results are going to
be based on flattening the curve in a
serious manner but that's not this
administration's priority Trump's
priority is getting reelected in
November that's his gambit his idea is
anything I can do in the next three and
a half months that will make it seem as
though life is returning to normal will
benefit me politically and that is the
only thing that he cares about now
unfortunately the timing hasn't worked
out because instead of a nice gap now
leading into the election with few cases
and few deaths we're seeing a massive
resurgence which shouldn't surprise us
because when we got down to 20,000 cases
a day States went crazy reopening and
now we're seeing that resurgence now I'm
gonna be totally upfront with you guys
about something because this came up on
the bonus show yesterday sort of briefly
and people wrote to me and they said
David I want to hear more about this I
know some people may be mad because not
everybody is in a position to be able to
do this because they have different
types of jobs things are potentially
going to get so bad here in the United
States and it's even going to bleed into
Massachusetts I am seriously looking at
finding the
it is it possible I could do the show
from somewhere else in the fall where I
could get a break from what's going on
in the United States and just be
somewhere else and by that I mean
another country now of course the
problem is Americans are banned from
much of the world right now because it's
so bad here so I've not looked into it
in a huge amount of detail but would it
be possible to put the mask on take a
coronavirus test quarantine 14 days and
if I'm going to be you know just
buckling in and riding it out for three
or four months maybe that is something I
would actually be interested in doing
because the reality is what it
increasingly looks like is the best case
best case it takes two months for a
lockdown to have a big impact we saw it
in New York if Texas Florida you know
etc lockdown today we're looking at
large case numbers at least until
mid-september they don't look like they
want to do full lockdown so we could be
looking at this going well into the fall
if Joe Biden wins in November and we get
the most optimistic timeline with an
early use vaccine for health care
workers at that point in time
optimistically things aren't going to
really dramatically improve until early
2021 that that's just an unfortunate
reality Joe Biden will hopefully take
over then treatments and vaccinations
will hopefully start to become a reality
in the short term hopefully we see
governors and mayor's do the right thing
but when you're seeing 5 7 10 15,000
cases a day in some states like we're
seeing right now the best cases you need
months to come down from numbers that
high and I understand that I'm truly
privileged to live in Massachusetts I
can't imagine what my friends in Florida
Arizona California Texas are going
through right now and it's going to
remain incredibly ugly for a long time
if there's any good news it's that some
governors and mayors seem to be taking
this seriously let me know what's going
on in your city or state I'm on twitter
at des Pakman and remember to get the
daily audio podcast on Spotify stitch or
iTunes Google Play wherever you prefer
to listen to your audience the david
pakman show at david pakman
[Music]
what if you could read ten books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinka Stan what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinka snakes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blankets to get
a sample first just think how much you
can enrich yourself by being able to
soak up an entire nonfiction book in
just 15 minutes I recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
Stephen Hawking this is a book that I
have been aware of for so long and other
things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
accom slash david pakman I've put the
link right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are joseph Fazio and lance herring
thanks Joseph and glance also a big
THANK YOU to David Hackett who is
today's longtime sustaining member of
the day remember that membership is the
number one funding source for the
podcast the YouTube channel the live
streams the newsletter all of the
different things that we do you can sign
up at join pakman.com it's quick it's
simple it's easy and it's a beautiful
thing it's been a couple of weeks but it
is time for hate reott mail what is
hatred mail here's a reminder if you're
allowed to shop for luxuries like food
and medicine then we should be allowed
to clap our hands together in a
megachurch patriot mail written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom this one is
pretty brutal
this one's pretty brutal the anti
Semitism is back in full swing
take a look I'm more tired of this Jew
David Park man than I've ever been
why are Jews so opinionated one Jew two
opinions two Jews four opinions for Jews
eight opinions exponential but this guy
is a denier of Christ so of goes with
the territory
a Jew from Argentina imagine that
trespasser on top of everything else I
admit though Hispanic Ashkenazi he's
damn handsome hate him though this
person seems strangely attracted to me
despite their anti-semitism that that's
kind of different I guess
the hate mail lately that I've been
getting it's a lot of masks and economy
stuff it's kind of conspiratorial it's
overwhelmingly you know I'm part of some
conspiracy to shut down the economy to
hurt Donald Trump coronavirus is a hoax
masks don't do anything or may actually
be killing people that's been a lot of
it and no good conspiracy theory in the
United
is missing anti-semitism so a lot of it
is tied into its the Jews who want
people wearing masks or it's the Jews
who want to shut down the economy or
whatever it's very very vile stuff but
remember that you can fight hatred ISM
by using the coupon code hey tree at 40
to get a 40% discount off of the
membership of your choice at join
pakman.com you save 40 percent with the
coupon code hey tree at 40 the hey tree
it's cry and independent media benefits
that spelled h80 our i/o t40
you know I've been suspecting more and
more over the last few weeks that Donald
Trump may not realize that in the
context of voting in November absentee
ballots and mail-in ballots are exactly
the same thing now Donald Trump hasn't
specifically said absentee is fine but
mailing is bad or at least he hadn't up
until a few days ago but in his attacks
against vote-by-mail and his defenses of
absentee voting I got the sense that
Trump seems to think we're talking about
two totally different things we've now
removed all doubt Donald Trump does
think absentee ballots and mail-in
ballots are two different things one of
which is fine the other is totally
subject to rampant fraud now remember
that the context of this entire anti
vote-by-mail thing is related to
coronavirus the idea is it may be too
dangerous to go out and have large
crowds voting in November we're gonna be
in the middle of a pandemic in all
likelihood some states will be worse off
than others and we should allow anyone
who wants to to vote by mail by getting
an absentee ballot mail-in ballot
absentee ballot in this context it's the
same thing now I want to issue one
caveat because I know I'll get some
trolls or maybe people just genuinely
misunderstanding in theory if there was
just regular vote by mail as a matter of
course
rather than a process for voting by mail
through absentee ballots there could be
a difference between people are allowed
to request an absentee ballot versus an
entire state
or country switches to exclusively
voting by mail as a matter of course
those could be different things for
November what we're talking about is
just expanding accent absentee ballot
access to anybody that wants an absentee
ballot so with that context
check out these quotes these tweets from
Donald Trump where it's clear he thinks
these are two different things
he says quote mail-in ballot fraud found
in many elections people are just now
seeing how bad dishonest and slow it is
election results could be delayed for
months no more big election night
answers 1% not even counted in 2016
ridiculous just a formula for rigging an
election absentee ballots are fine
because you have to go through a precise
process to get your voting privilege not
so with Malins rigged election 20%
fraudulent ballots so Donald Trump
clearly believes these are two different
things it sounds like he thinks an
absentee ballot is something you request
but a mail-in is you just I don't know
you just get it somehow you don't have
to go through some kind of process so
remember for November in the United
States what we're talking about is
expanding vote by mail by allowing
anybody who wants an absentee ballot to
get one normally to get an absentee
ballot in most states some states have
open absentee ballot requests normally
to vote by absentee ballot you have to
meet certain criteria either you you
know have a medical condition where you
can't go to the polls you're living
elsewhere temporarily you're living out
of the country's ins you still go
through the same application process
though if you expand absentee ballots to
say anybody can get an absentee ballot
so there's sort of a few layers here one
layer is you say anybody who wants an
absentee ballot is allowed to request
one no matter what the reason that would
be one one way the next layer would be
every registered voter gets an absentee
ballot application automatically if they
want to vote absentee they have to
return that application in any case this
is all totally
simple standard stuff now again in
theory you could have a 100%
vote-by-mail system that is not merely
an expansion of the absentee ballot
system that we have that's not what
we're talking about for November we do
not have that nobody is talking about
that for November for November we're
talking about anybody who wants an
absentee ballot can request one in some
states hopefully every registered voter
will be sent an application it is not
every person Trump wants to make you
believe that you know hundreds of
thousands of undocumented immigrants who
are never registered to vote because
they can't vote in California are gonna
be set absentee ballots no applications
or ballots will be sent to registered
voters now I was thinking maybe the move
here is to placate Trump imagine
Democrats go to trump and they say you
know sir as he likes to say you're right
vote by mail is too dangerous you win
instead we're going to just expand
absentee ballots we're not gonna do vote
by mail will expand absentee is he that
uninformed that maybe he would go for it
now the reality is that Trump wants
absentee ballot voting or vote by mail
for himself he wants it for his family
he wants it for Kay Lima Kennedy he
wants it for people planning to vote for
him he does not want it to be easier or
safer to vote for people planning to
vote for Joe Biden at the core of it yes
Trump is ignorant yes Trump seems to
think there's a difference between
absentee ballots and mail-in voting in
this particular election but ultimately
what this is really about is Trump is
losing on the issues his polling is in
the garbage and he's looking to win in
other ways and suppressing turnout is a
great way for Donald Trump to try to win
we can't allow it to happen we have to
so overwhelm the vote in November that
none of these garbage techniques are
going to work and that depends on every
single person voting and getting out the
vote that's ultimately what this is
going to come down to we know they're
going to try to suppress we know they're
going to do everything they can
what October surprises can they put
they're gonna do it all they're gonna
throw everything at the wall and see
what sticks we just all have to vote
that's that's the way if enough of us
vote it won't be enough we will over
well
all of those tactics that they are going
to apply we're going to have more of
this topic and discussion on the David
Pakman show
Instagram page that's david pakman show
on instagram make sure you're following
us there and for the latest garden
updates you should see what's going on
with my zucchini it's it's it's like
nothing I've ever seen before doctors
were shocked at how my garden has aced
zucchini growing
follow me on Instagram for those updates
at david hockney the david pakman show
at david pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world's
famous bonus show as well as commercial
free audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at join
pakman.com coupon code saves you 40%
vote soon 18 welcome back to the David
Pakman show yesterday afternoon I got
back from just a beautiful bike ride
here in the city of Boston and I was not
planning on doing a live stream until
our chess tournament later at night but
it was announced that Donald Trump
called an urgent press conference set to
start at 5 p.m. Eastern yesterday and
this was pretty unusual it hadn't been
on the schedule for the entire day and
it was framed as urgent and potentially
bringing some kind of big announcement I
decided to do a live stream because if
there's something major that's going to
happen let's see what it is and share it
with the audience and we wondered maybe
they were announcing a second stimulus
package maybe there's some kind of big
announcement related to coronavirus what
could it be it seems like something big
is going on so I did a live stream and
clearly news of this urgent press
conference spread widely because instead
of having our normal six to eight
thousand viewers on YouTube we had more
than 40,000 people watched the live
stream concurrently across our platforms
and it ended up being more than an hour
of Donald Trump wildly and belligerently
attacking Joe Biden in a completely
incoherent manner followed by taking
just three questions not really
answering any of them and one of those
three questions came from the outrageous
propaganda right-wing news outlet Oh a n
and this was actually so insane and so
unprecedented that even Fox News anchor
Bret Baier had no choice but to mention
listen Barack Obama did this Barack
Obama called an urgent press conference
at the White House and delivered what
was essentially a campaign speech
attacking his opponent even if it was a
poor campaign speech Republicans would
have lost their minds saying it's an
abuse of power it's an abuse of the
status of the White House here is Bret
Baier
actually being honest and saying it
spoke for 52 minutes before taking a
question presidents in the past by
tradition have stayed away from overt
campaign rhetoric from the Rose Garden
or the White House but it is the
president's discretion it is worth
noting however to be fair that had
President Obama made this kind of speech
from the Rose Garden Republicans on
Capitol Hill would likely have been up
in arms but this comes 112 days 16 weeks
to the day before Election Day even
Brett Beier realizes this was hugely
outrageous and Republic Republicans are
major hypocrites now of course there are
people talking about the legal question
like is this using taxpayer money for
campaigning in the sense that this was
really a campaign event where the focus
was attacking Trump's opponent but it
was at the White House with the White
House press corps not campaign people
covering the campaign but as good of an
argument as that might be
I just wouldn't focus much on it because
it's going nowhere the focus really
should be that this is a very desperate
Donald Trump that clearly nobody around
him can control and I know that Trump
has a lot of very bad people around him
whose instincts are terrible but it's
hard to imagine that even they would be
supportive of this it genuinely seems
like on a whim sometime around 4:00 p.m.
Eastern yesterday Trump said put
together a list for me of things I can
say about Joe Biden and let's call an
urgent press conference and then I'm
just gonna go out there and read the
list and that's how poorly it came off
Trump was asked about the fact that his
polling is in the toilet and Trump
mentioned you know there are some
Floridians with boats who seem to like
me I'm not kidding that was Trump's
answer to one of the few questions he
took I don't I think we have really good
poll numbers they're not suppression
Pauls they're real polls you look at the
intercoastal in Florida you look at the
lakes you see thousands of boats with
Trump signs American signs you've got
the Trump pin sign all over you look at
what's going on you look at bikers for
miles and miles writing up highways
proudly with their signs
thousands of boat owners in Florida love
Trump that's his answer when faced with
polling data and described
the polls by saying their suppression
polls Trump wildly after stumbling over
an acronym claims that Joe Biden wants
to end the suburbs take a look
abolish in the suburbs you're going to
abolish the separations with this
enforce Obama Biden's radical AFF H
that's the AFF H regulation that
threatens to strip localities of federal
affordable housing funds unless they
change their zoning laws to fit the
federal government's demands so what you
have I mean I've been watching this for
years in Westchester coming from New
York they want a low-income housing
built in a neighborhood well I'm ending
that rule I'm taking it out so I had
spoke with Ben Carson the other day
we're gonna be taking it out I've
watched that whole thing go and now they
want to make it twice as bad in the
suburbs in the suburbs mothers aren't
happy about that fathers aren't happy
about that they worked hard to buy a
house and now they're going to watch the
housing values drop like a rock and that
has happened Trump just barely able to
get through the reading but says Joe
Biden wants to end the suburbs just kind
of aimlessly stumbling around here's
just like a random 60 seconds where
you'll notice Donald Trump is just
jumping from topic to topic with no
rhyme or reason making absolutely no
sense and I believe this is the clip
where you get a shot of the press and
they're just still there like statues
they don't know what the hell is going
on many countries and I did this myself
for the most part not to use Huawei
because we think it's an unsafe security
risk it's a big security risk
I talked many countries out of using it
if they want to do business with us they
can't use it just today I believe that
UK announced that they're not going to
be using it and that was up in the air
for a long time but they've decided and
you look at Italy you look at many other
countries we withdrew from the Chinese
dominated WHL
and we fully rebuilt the United States
military the WHL World Health
Organization we were paying close to 500
million dollars a year China is paying
39 million dollars a year and China had
too much say they worked it very hard
which is a bad thing done by our past
administrations but we were tough and we
were saying I was asking I said why are
we paying so much more than China just
all over the place I mean really really
bizarre just one other clip for you here
here Donald Trump claims that this is so
crazy
he claims that Joe Biden is against
windows like now I'm not talking about
the Windows operating system he's not
saying Joe Biden's a Mac guy he's saying
if Joe Biden were president buildings
wouldn't have windows heating cooling or
lighting mandate net zero carbon
emissions for homes offices and all new
buildings by 2030 that basically means
no windows no nothing it's very hard to
do I tell people when they want to go
into some of these buildings how are
your eyes because they won't be good in
five years and I hope you don't mind
cold office space in the winter and warm
office space in the summer because your
air conditioning is not the same as the
good old days this is so crazy and it
reminds me of what I think at this point
I don't know if it was like six months
ago or a year ago remember that rant
where Donald Trump said Democrats don't
want you to have good flushing toilets
likes it's just stuff about water
pressure and saying just really really
bizarre so what we had here in the end
is that Donald Trump manipulated
reporters to get them to go to the White
House to rant to them about Joe Biden
and if I was on the fence about voting
for Trump I mean listen I know that if
you're in the tank for Trump you don't
care you probably
didn't even watch this in fact there's a
lot of Trumpets who in order to avoid
being confronted with his incompetence
no longer even watch Trump's public
facing events they're just voting for
Trump they don't want to hear anything
else about it if you were already not
voting for Trump obviously this press
conference this ranting is not going to
convince you to vote for Donald Trump
I'm imagining even though I don't really
get how anyone could be undecided at
this point if you were one of these
undecided voters could this possibly
convince you to vote for Donald Trump
and if again I don't know how anyone is
undecided I'm not sure if there's any of
these undecided voters in my audience
but if you are one of those people I
would love to hear your perspective on
Trump calling an urgent press conference
at the last second and then struggling
to read criticisms of Joe Biden off of
his pieces of paper it is very very
bizarre before we go to a break
I do have kind of a cool announcement as
some of you know I am a very bad amateur
chess player and over the last few
months we've engaged with our audience
by occasionally running a chess
tournament we had one last night with
728 players it was a great time
apparently word of my amateur chess
playing has gotten around and I have
been invited by chess comm to be one of
16 participants in a chess tournament
next month called pogchamp stu pogchamp
one was last month grandmaster Hikaru
Nakamura reached out to me I said I
would love to do it the chess comm team
reached out to me I said I would love to
do it so that's where we are right now
I have been assigned excellent
professional chess player coaches to
coach me from the standpoint of being a
participant in this tournament and I am
probably going to be doing most of the
coaching sessions over on Twitch and the
first one is tonight at 8:30 p.m.
Eastern so this is not going to be like
the normal oh my Sharpie is collapsing
this is not going to be the normal sort
of stream this is going to be twitch
only tonight at 8:30 and it will be the
start of my journey in preparing for
this tournament that will be taking
place in August so join me tonight on
which at twitch.tv slash David Pakman I
will be introducing you to my first of
two actually really three different
chess coaches that I'm going to have I'm
that bad that I need multiple coaches
sadly but it'll be a good time it'll be
a nice break from all the politics
tonight so we'll take a quick break I
will see you in just a couple of minutes
but then hopefully tonight as my chess
pogchamp s-- adventure begins the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
we've been wondering for a while now and
sort of asking questions about whether
we can trust the coronavirus numbers
that we're getting and part of the
reason why that's been in question is
that there have been reports that
individual states were choosing to
suppress data maybe not so much about
cases but possibly about deaths Florida
was one place where we heard those
allegations made very specifically but
now we have to talk about this at the
federal level because there are growing
reports that the Trump administration is
coordinating a suppression effort to
prevent the real numbers about
coronavirus from getting out and we've
actually gotten our hands on a memo that
was sent out which specifically says to
hospitals as of today July 15 stop
sending the data to the CDC instead send
it to the Department of Health and Human
Services run by Trump tool and sycophant
Alex a czar this is exactly what we
predicted might happen months ago if the
numbers did not improve the New York
Times reported yesterday that hospitals
have been ordered to bypass the normal
process the normal process is hospitals
report to the CDC and they were told
send us all of your data send it
directly to the Department of Health and
Human Services this is the opposite of
transparency this opens the door to just
hiding the data and health experts
obviously are alarmed because they know
exactly how this can go now we
eventually got a copy of the order from
the Trump administration and what the
document says to hospitals is don't send
your information that the CDC send it to
us and of course that is a department
the Department of Health and Human
Services that is run by the guide Trump
picked and who has been brown-nosing
Trump's since the start of this pandemic
and in all of history since the CDC was
created pandemic data health data like
what we're dealing with today goes to
the CDC the Kaiser Family Foundation
which has no connection whatsoever to
the insurance company Kaiser Permanente
the Kaiser Family Foundation says quote
this is Jen Cates the director of global
health and HIV policy jen kate says
historically the CDC has been the place
where public health data has been sent
and this raises questions
I love the understated nature this
raises questions about not just access
for researchers but access for reporters
access for the public to try to better
understand what is happening with the
outbreak
how will the data be protected will
there be transparency will there be
access and what is the role of the CDC
in understanding the data now
you need only zoom out like the tiniest
bit to understand what is most likely
going on here Donald Trump admitted that
he wanted to slow down testing in order
to cover up the reality of the pandemic
remember he said one of the reasons we
have so many cases is we have so many
tests now this ignores a whole bunch of
realities in fact if you don't test it
doesn't affect the real number of cases
except it probably increases the real
number of cases because without testing
people don't know they have the virus
and they go out and they spread it so
not testing actually spreads the disease
additionally as testing has gone up in
many of the states that are worst
affected the positivity rate has gone up
if you go from 5,000 to 10,000 tests a
day and you go from having 2 percent of
the people test positive to 4 percent
that is a signal of a growing epidemic
this is all way beyond Donald Trump he
doesn't seem to understand any of this
stuff so the point is once you
understand Trump admitted to wanting to
slow down testing to slow down case
numbers and you see that the Trump
administration is saying to hospitals
don't send your data to the CDC send
your data the Alex a czar at HHS the
obvious next step is to start covering
up this data cover-up death data
cover-up hospitalization data the White
House is trying to muzzle the normal
reporting process and the only reason
that that exists is to suppress
information if he can't stop the testing
he'll stop the information now I'm
hoping I don't I don't know I've talked
to a few people today and they have
different opinions that could this work
because there are other ways to get the
data out media will talk to hospitals
and hospitals were say wills will say
we're full
we have no room in the ICU for example
and at a certain point if the data that
the Trump administration is allowing to
be published says one thing that goes
completely against what the ICU
information is at a certain point you
would hope that it would explode that
the real data has been covered up I
don't know I mean I'm hopeful that this
can't really be covered up to this
degree but the administration has
decided the numbers must go down that
the numbers have to go down for the
benefit of donald trump's reelection
here's one way to do it now what we can
hope for is that we still find the data
and that trump is punished electorally
for trying to suppress the data rather
than dealing with the pandemic itself
it's too early to know which way it will
go because the directive starts today
it's effective as of July 15th so we'll
have to see what happens but what we
need to understand is that from this
point forward from as if this wasn't
already the case in many of the states
in the United States already from this
point forward we have to realize that
the numbers that make it out may not be
the real numbers because the idea is
hide the data to justify a faster
economic opening to help Donald Trump
get himself reelected his re-election is
the most important factor it's far more
important than American lives and it's
really the only thing you need to know
to understand how to analyze the actions
of this administration it seems to run
counter to health it seems to run
counter to common sense it seems
short-sighted in terms of the economy
because the relapse effect will hurt the
economy you just have to understand
Trump thinks it might help him get
reelected in November that's all that's
going on the pandemic response has been
blown so badly that there's really no
way to fix it before the election I was
looking at some data today and this is
important for you to understand when New
York hit its peak right around April 12
April 15
something like that that's when New York
had its peak of cases it took two full
months with strict lock downs for New
York cases to come down remember that
death slag cases by about 15 to 20 days
so by ok April May June by mid-june you
finally had this improving in New York
and only in the last 10 days in July
have New Yorks death numbers really
finished coming down to you know a
number that hopefully they won't spike
again from so you take that model to
months for cases and then another 15 or
so days for deaths if Arizona and
Florida and Texas fully locked down
today if that they don't even want you
but if they did that you're looking at
September 15th to get cases under
control and October 1st to get what is
the coming spike of deaths back under
control they're not willing to do it I
mean yeah Greg Abbott now is saying more
you got to wear a mask but these are not
places that seem to have an appetite
politically or economically or in any
other way for a full lockdown
so Trump recognizes the numbers aren't
going to be under control when you get
to 10 15,000 cases a day that doesn't
just go away in two weeks
they are going to be dealing with
widespread outbreaks until close to
election time if we have the surging
second wave by then it could be even
worse we're now hearing from the CDC
that this fall may be one of the most
difficult times in American history
from the standpoint of Public Health so
what can Trump do just lie cover up the
data that's all that they can do is hide
the data use the data well use the data
you're willing to publish which is not
accurate to say we should reopen reopen
in order to make things seem normal so
that people will vote for you in the
fall hopefully the real data makes it
out but this is now taking on the sort
of color of a full cover-up because the
actual remember it would have been
rather than covering up data changing
reporting procedure all of the stuff it
would have been much easier to just deal
with the virus from the get
that's not what this administration
chose to do there's a very interesting
side story going on given that we're
talking about coronavirus and Florida
and from selection there's a side story
that kind of pulls together coronavirus
Florida Trump 2020 and more and the
story is about the 2020 Republican
National Convention which is now in
jeopardy and more and more Republicans
are saying I'm not going to Florida to a
huge convention that doesn't seem safe
at all and Donald Trump is now going to
have to balance the risk of holding a
mass event in one of the global hotspots
not just national hotspots Florida is a
global coronavirus hotspot Trump would
have to say what are gonna be the optics
of doing that
what happens if turnout is terrible
because that's also the other side of
this right now so to catch you up
the RNC was supposed to be in North
Carolina this summer
North Carolina's governor said you can't
do it at full capacity we just can't
given what's going on with coronavirus
Trump was upset he moved it to Florida
instead a lunatic Republican governor
Ron de santis is like sure do whatever
you want the latest news is that many
Republicans are saying they're not going
to go mitt romney's not going that's not
a huge surprise because he's been one of
the most vocal anti Trump Republicans
right now but other Republicans are
bailing as well senators Roy Blunt and
Pat Roberts said no go a Florida
congressman Francis Rooney is
increasingly looking like he's not going
to be there Marco Rubio sounds to be on
the fence he's the senator from Florida
imagine having an RNC in Florida to
nominate Trump and one of the two
senators from that state doesn't go
Senator John Thune Liz Cheney there's a
lot of Republican elected officials who
are saying and it's not seeming like a
good idea
Republican Senator Chuck Grassley is a
question mark now consider the hypocrisy
of this given that Republicans want
schools reopened we had a hundred
thousand active cases in the country in
march/april and it was deemed too
dangerous to go to school so schools
were closed we had a hundred thousand
cases closed it down
we now have 1.8 million active
infections
and Republicans are saying open up the
schools but I'm not going to the
convention that's way too dangerous and
these examples are very widespread you
know it's too dangerous for Paul
Manafort to be in prison because of
coronavirus but all schools should
reopen so this convention thing could
end up being a problem at this point for
Donald Trump no matter what now we talk
about self-inflicted damage he spent
months saying the convention will happen
if it doesn't he looks weak so that's
potentially a problem for Donald Trump
if he does the convention there's the
problem of spreading coronavirus in a
state that is wracked with one of the
worst outbreaks of coronavirus in the
world if Florida were a country it would
have one of the worst coronavirus
outbreaks in the world and if Trump does
it and the turnout is low
he gets the bad optics of spreading
coronavirus plus the bad optics of
people not showing up so once again
self-inflicted damage now meanwhile I
don't even care about a Democratic
National Convention I mean listen I'm
voting for Biden I I know what the right
move is in November I don't need a
convention I don't need debates it's
just such a clear choice keep people
safe and remove Donald Trump in November
let's move on get Biden inaugurated in
January hopefully we'll have better
functioning therapeutics more production
of monoclonal antibodies convalescent
plasma maybe an early use vaccine
hopefully we'll start start to be
available from a circus standpoint of
course I would love to see the debates I
would love to see the convention our
live streams would do so well streaming
this stuff but I don't want anybody
getting sick and dying even the
sycophants that would show up to a
convention in Florida in the middle of a
pandemic would be exactly the people
that wouldn't want to wear masks and
would be most likely to spread disease
so you know I I would love to see
conventions but they're only every four
years I would love to see the debates
but the truth is we don't need them we
all know what the right thing to do is
in November now as a reminder the real
reason they want schools open is not for
education it's not for the mental health
of the students it's they need the
economy to look
many parents can't work if their kids
aren't in school that's really at the
crux of it if you believe that your
re-election hinges on things like things
seeming normal you want schools open
because so much depends on schools being
open putting cars back on the road
parents going to work businesses opening
a lot of it is connected to the daily
routine of parents getting their kids to
school that is all that Trump cares
about if you care about health you've
got to look elsewhere you're not going
to get anything health based from this
administration we have a voicemail
number which I invite you to call
absolutely any time of day that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
voicemail with a question about maybe
how we might interpret the current state
of a political affairs take a look yeah
hey dave i'm gonna mention something
when nobody's mentioned yet I believe
the David or Donald Trump presents
presidency is revenge for electing a
black man as President Barack Obama tell
you what this is why the Republicans are
letting that go I've never heard this
mentioned I believe this is true listen
I have heard it mentioned this idea that
the reason Trump got elected is a racist
response to Barack Obama now what's
really I'm gonna address that in a
second there's a slice of the left that
likes to say Barack Obama's centrism and
failing the middle class is what got
Trump elected there's people on the Left
who like to say that in order to then
say as a result the last thing we need
is Joe Biden because it'll just lead to
another Donald Trump I think that this
is actually an interesting idea that the
caller presents which is that there was
such racist rage about Barack Obama that
there are people who would not maybe
normally have voted for Donald Trump but
did in order to punish the Democratic
Party for electing a black man
I think it exists I don't know that it's
the predominant factor I do think that
there are a lot of race related elements
including the fear of losing status as
some middle-class white voters may may
have experienced I don't think that
straight-up racism is really responsible
for Donald Trump in the way racist
backlash I guess we would call it in the
way this caller is referring to mmm but
in a country of 331 million people
there's a little bit of everything right
James commis press conference about
Hillary probably swung some votes racism
in response to Barack Obama probably
swung some votes Russian social media
campaigns swung some votes you can't say
that it's one thing but it's certainly
an interesting component we have a great
bonus show planned for you today Burger
King is wanting to address climate
change by changing the diets of cows
where it gets its meat what we'll talk
about that we will also talk about a new
study which shows that minimum wage in
any US state does not allow you to
afford rent okay
horrifying numbers and I'm actually
going to do it I'm gonna talk a little
bit about cue cue an on cue a nun cannon
as I like to call it sometimes on
today's bonus show get instant access to
the bonus show at join pakman.com
today's bonus show is a good one
otherwise I'll see you tomorrow
thanks so much for watching today's a
full episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinka the app that
lets you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try bling kissed for free and save
25% off of a subscription when you go to
blink is comm slash david pakman i've
also included the link right underneath
this video